gott sei Dank ist die Nabelschau
zwischen Herrn Merz und dem
Bundeskanzler vorbei sie haben damit
eindeutig gezeigt dass ihnen die
Ernsthaftigkeit fehlt für die Lage in
der sich unser Land befindet deutschland
steuert in den schwersten Sturm seit
bestehender Bundesrepublik Millionen
Existenzen stehen auf dem Spiel
zahllosen Bürgern droht die Verarmung
der mittelständischen Wirtschaft der
Zusammenbruch den Staatsfinanzen
dauerhafte Zerrüttung
und auf der Brücke der startschiffs
steht der Kapitän der Titanic will von
Eisbergen nichts wissen und
beschwichtigt die Leute mit hohlen
Durchsagen das haben wir ja gerade
gehört
mit so einer Besatzung kann die Reise
nur im Desaster enden ein Bundeskanzler
der in einen Steuer- und Finanzskandal
verwickelt ist und sicher nichts
erinnern kann ein Wirtschaftsminister
der die Bürger schöpft um Lobbyisten und
Energiekonzernen zu geben aber von
ökonomischen und technologischen
Zusammenhängen überhaupt gar keine
Ahnung hat und nicht mal weiß was
Insolvenzen sind wir als gestern Abend
in der Talkshow ja von sich gegeben hat
ein Finanzminister der
schuldensystematisch verschleiert eine
Innenministerin die auf dem linken Auge
blind ist beim Islamismus wegschaut und
den Verfassungsschutz als etablierten
schutzmissbraucht ein Justizminister der
willkürlich Grundrechte einschränkt ein
von einem Virus Besessener
Gesundheitsminister der laufen wäre es
und unsinniges von sich gibt eine
Verteidigungsministerin die mit
militärischem Gerät offenbar nur dann
etwas anfangen kann wenn zum
urlaubsvehikel taugt und schließlich
eine grüne Außenministerin die
verspricht an der Seite der Ukraine zu
stehen gleichgültig wie hart und
verheerend die sanktions-
ihr Amtseid Schaden vom deutschen Volk
abzuwenden wird zum Meineid ideologische
Phantasien und arrogantes Festhalten an
Fehlentscheidungen sind ihnen wichtiger
ihr verbohrtes Festhalten Abschalten der
letzten Kernkraftwerke ist dafür der
beste Beleg sie ruinieren dieses Land
wirtschaftlich um die irrationalen
Dogmen der Grünen Klientel und
Lobbyisten zu bedienen sie haben allen
Grund einen heißen Herbst und Winter zu
fürchten denn die Bürger haben jedes
Recht Herr Merz gegen eine solche
Regierung und gegen eine solche Politik
auf die Straße zu gehen natürlich haben
Sie das Recht
galoppierende Inflation
eine sterbende Währung und explodierende
Energiepreise bedeuten für Millionen
Bürger mehr als nur ein bisschen frieren
wie in gönnerhaft von oben mitgeteilt
wird auch für Haushalte der
Mittelschicht geht das an die Existenz
sie können Ihre Rechnung nicht mehr
bezahlen ihre Rücklagen Renten und
Versorgungsansprüche werden rasant
entwertet ihnen droht Verarmung und
Abhängigkeit
von öffentlicher Fürsorge die aber
endlich ist wie wir heute bereits sehen
in der Schöpfung der Steuerzahler bis in
die Existenzvernichtung viele die heute
noch ihre Familien ernähren können
werden ihre Arbeit verlieren
reihenweise Stellen mittelständische
Unternehmen bereits jetzt die Produktion
ein weil sie die Energierechnung nicht
mehr stemmen können Bäcker und Dünger
Fabriken Porzellan und Glashersteller
Gießereien und Aluminiumwerke
Inflation und Energiekrise zerstören den
unternehmerischen Mittelstand und die
bürgerliche Mittelschicht ihr
Entlastungspaket hat für unseren
Mittelstand und für unsere Mittelschicht
nichts übrig
sie versprechen Zuschüsse die die
arbeitende Bevölkerung selbst bezahlen
muss
sie verteilen Geld dass sie den Bürgern
vorher mehrfach weggenommen haben und
stellen das als Wohltat da
60 Prozent der deutschen Haushalte
müssen ihre gesamten Einkünfte nach
Steuern
für die Lebenshaltung einsetzen zum
Sparen bleibt nichts mehr als eine
sparkassenstudie sie müssen nicht mit
dem Kopf schütteln hier bei den Grünen
sondern sie müssen einfach die Studien
lesen dass Sie das nicht wollen noch
keine Ahnung davon haben das beweisen
sie mit ihrer Politik wenn das das grüne
Wirtschaftswunder ist
das im Wahlkampf angekündigt wurde dann
danke für mich und ihre scheinheiligen
Appelle und Durchhalteparolen an die
Bürger sich einzuschränken
Opfer zu bringen und kalt zu duschen
Waschlappen zu benutzen für die Ukraine
für die Energiewende oder für ein Klima
das können Sie sich sparen das wollen
die Leute nicht hören um in dieser Krise
zu bestehen muss unser Land die Ursachen
von Inflationen Energiekrise angehen
davon habe ich von ihnen nichts gehört
in dieser Aussprache Inflation und
Energiepreise ziehen schon seit mehr als
einem Jahr an bei der Entwicklung sind
das direkte Resultat einer schlechten
jahrzehntelangen Politik die
Energiekrise ist hausgemacht sie ist
direkte Folge der Energiewende die mit
ihrem abschalt waren und torrenten
Steuern und Abgaben Strom künstlich
verknackt und verteuert hat und uns in
eine einseitige Abhängigkeit von
russischen Erdgas geführt hat das ist
doch die Wahrheit die Grünen sollen doch
nicht so tun
es ist hier angestrebtes Ziel die
Energiekosten in die Höhe zu treiben und
damit die Nachfrage einzuschränken das
Ziel haben sie jetzt ja damit erreicht
die Inflation ist zudem das Resultat der
maßlosen Geldschöpfung zu
Nullzinspolitik der EZB zur Finanzierung
hoch verschuldeter und aufgeblähter
Staatshaushalte zweieinhalb Jahre
lockdown-politik und eine kopflose
Sanktionspolitik als Reaktion auf den
Ukraine Krieg haben das Kartenhaus zum
Einsturz gebracht die Konsequenzen
liegen auf der Hand
nur ihre Regierung wie sie nicht sehen
und die entsprechenden Maßnahmen nicht
ergreifen erstens die Steuern müssen
runter Senkung der Energiesteuern der
Mehrwert und der Einkommensteuer
Streichung der
CO2-Abgabe und eine echte Streichung und
Abschaffung des unsäglichen EEG
zweitens
dezb muss in die Pflicht genommen werden
Ihren Auftrag zu erfüllen und für
stabiles Geld zu sorgen drittens die
Staatsausgaben müssen auf das
Wesentliche konzentriert werden innere
und äußere Sicherheit Gewährleistung von
Rechtsstaatlichkeit und öffentlicher
Ordnung Schluss mit ideologiepolitik
klientelversorgung und Geld verteilen in
alle Welt 4
illegale Migration Veränderungen in die
Sozialsysteme liegen schon wieder über
dem Niveau von 2015 aber sie öffnen die
letzten Schleusen und senden neue
migrationssignale durch fast schon
bedingungslose Einbürgerung 5 das
Energieangebot muss ausgeweitet werden
wir müssen Energieerzeugung und
Energieimporte
entmoraliieren das heißt im Klartext
Schluss mit der ressourcenvergeordnung
für Windkraft und Photovoltaik sie sind
nicht krisenfest und ich
versorgungssicher Windkraft treten nur
einen Bruchteil der installierten
Leistung zur Versorgung bei Kernkraft
nahezu 100 Prozent sechstens
Normalisierung der Gasimporte aus
Russland und wenn erforderlich Öffnung
von nordstream 2 ja natürlich 7
Laufzeitverlängerung für die noch
aktiven Kernkraftwerke Reaktivierung der
zuletzt stillgelegten und natürlich dem
Bau neuer Kraftwerke wir brauchen die
Kernkraft für eine saubere sichere und
bezahlbare Energie
und schön dass die CDU das jetzt auch
allmählich zu begreifen scheint Herr
März ihrer Partei die seit 16 Jahren
nach der grünen roten Pfeife Tanz haben
wir diese Misere überhaupt erst zu
verdanken die Energiewende ins Nichts
ist Resultat ihrer Politik und 16 Jahre
Merkel und die Fortsetzung der
Energiewende und der Missbrauch der
Krise um sie noch zu forcieren
münden im sicheren Ruin die Bürger
dieses Landes die arbeitende Bevölkerung
und der Mittelstand die Industrie
brauchen Freiheit und Luft zum Atmen und
nicht immer neue Vorschriften und Gänge
lang und schon gar nicht brauchen sie
auch noch in dieser Lage das muss man
sich mal vorstellen ein neues
Infektionsschutzgesetz in den meisten
Ländern wird das Corona-Virus bereits
wie ein saisonales Grippevirus behandelt
ohne Maßnahmen Chaos maskenzwang und
impfnötigung das Gesetz dass sie morgen
zur Abstimmung stellen wollen macht den
Ausnahmezustand zur Dauereinrichtung und
die
grundrechtseinschränkung zum Regelfall
schämen sie sich und das ist ein
Armutszeugnis für die FDP dass Sie sich
dafür hergibt dann nützt doch ein Kubik
hier nichts und aber vielleicht und das
ist so meine Vermutung wollen sie ja
jetzt schon eine Handhabe sichern um
Demonstrationen gegen ihre Politik durch
die die Türe desinfektionsschutzes zu
verbieten Frau Feser lässt ja gar keine
Gelegenheit aus um regierungskritische
Demonstration in die
rechtsradikalismusecke zu stellen was
für eine Bankrott Erklärung für diese
Regierung welche die Demonstration und
Meinungsfreiheit mit Füßen tritt beenden
Sie die deutsche Geisterfahrt in der
corona-energie und Migrationspolitik
kommen Sie zurück auf den Boden der
Tatsache
korrigieren Sie Ihre falsche Politik
statt immer neue Fehlentscheidungen zu
treffen ja das das steht in gut zu
Gesicht der Spott der Grünen merken Sie
sich das die Leute werden sich das
merken wie sie hier reagieren wie dieses
Land hier geradewegs an die Wand fährt
durch ihre Politik und wenn sie nicht
willens oder fähig sind ihren Kurs zu
ändern dann treten Sie bitte ab denn das
wäre das beste Entlastungspaket für
unser Land
[Applaus]